my name is chao wang
and i'm a science manager in the alexa
speech organization
today i'm going to be speaking to you
about acoustic event detection
audio is more than speech imagine the
universe of sounds
a baby crying two cars crashing to each
other or a gunshot going off
when we hear any of these sounds our
brain
is capable of identify them immediately
and then probably also infer what has
happened that caused them
so acoustic event detection uh sometimes
you'll hear me refer to them as
aed is an umbrella term that
refers to the technology of processing
audio
to understand sound um there are
actually a few different flavors to set
up the problem
audio tagging which is uh the task
of taking an audio input and try to
decide
if certain events are present in the
audio
acoustic event detection will try to not
only identify the sounds
the events but also try to determine
when did they happen
in that audio clip there's also
more complex tasks that pays attention
to more than just
a few events so for example acoustic
scene analysis
would rely on different combinations of
sounds that are characteristic of a
particular scene
to decide whether for example this is
an audio that indicates a train station
or a very peaceful lakefront
so what can we use audio acoustic event
detection
to bring new features to alexa customers
let me tell you about alexa guard so
most of the times when we interact
with alexa we talk to the device and ask
a question
and alexa would respond alexa guard
actually works when you are away from
your devices actually away from your
home
um imagine that you want alexa to keep
an eye
on your house when you when the house is
unoccupied
you can set alexa in guarding mode and
alexa would pay attention to certain
types of events
and then send you a notification if
these events were detected
um in 2019 we launched the capability of
detecting
sounds like glass breaking smoke or co
alarm
this year we're going to offer alexa
users the capability of monitoring for
human activities when they are away from
the home
so for example they want to deter
intruders uh
to their home and alexa can play sirens
when it detects human activities when
you don't
expect there should be human in your
home
we are also using acoustic event
detection to enable
a new feature we called sound detection
routines
um i'm not sure if you are aware of
routines feature in alexa um
this is the capability of allowing you
to customize
alexa's behavior uh without you having
to issue
uh the verbatim commands for example you
can set alexa
to have an alarm going off at six
o'clock and then tell you the weather
and then play your favorite radio
station or just by setting this as a
routine in your alexa app
and so sound detection routine would
allow the user to set
these kind of actions based on sound
triggers for example baby crying
snore or cough and imagine
you can say turn on the best master
bedroom light
if the baby cries so that new parents
would
make would be more assured that they'll
wake up
because the lights are on and they
wouldn't sleep through
a baby cry even
so and my talk was just a brief
mentioning of three papers we're
presenting in this conference
the first paper is about acoustic scene
analysis
as i mentioned acoustic scenes are
characterized by unique combinations of
sound patterns
so we talked about in this paper we
present
a methodology to use multi-head
attention network
to do this task and what's most
interesting to me is that
the attention head seems to be able to
capture hidden sound events that
corresponds to meaningful sound patterns
this next paper leverages
an effective methodology in the computer
vision
field to detect
objects within a an image
without having labels of the
object's specific location so we're
using this technology to do
acoustic event detection so that we use
only
the sound level uh annotation
uh but using this methodology to be able
to
tell actually where a particular target
event happens within
the uh the sound uh recording
the third paper is actually based on
an intern project chun chi chan is a
student
at um johns hopkins university who
interned us earlier this year um
his project explores the space of
knowledge distillation
knowledge distillation is a very
important technology
for my team because we're interested in
building
very compact efficient detectors that
can run
on devices but also still achieve the
same
or similar accuracy compared to much
larger
sophisticated models so this project
we explored the intrauterine similarity
as an additional constraints in
the training of the model
so with that we conclude our
presentation portion
of our session shiv arya andrew and
myself
will be joining the live webcam to
answer your questions
please start typing your questions in
the chat window and then we'll do our
best to answer
them thank you